foreign
ERS Guild strike now sag is striking
guess what no more Hollywood movies for
you
oh no yay oh so this is them asking some
of this that that's Fran I think that's
uh Fran Drescher with what is your
message to the fans and consumers who
aren't interested in the Nuance that
we're discussing here today they just
want their favorite TV shows or they
want to go to the movies
what makes you think they're not
interested in what's happening here
they're not they're not they're not
they're not a friend they're not they're
not interested these people live in this
[__] bubble well [__] bubble
I think that they have an allegiance to
all of us because
these are actors they have an allegiance
to us yes they have an allegiance these
Millionaires and [__] people that
live these [__] life they really
think
that they you owe them buying buying
giving them money and buying their films
that isn't enough all right and then
buying their stupid skin care products
and goop and all that [__] that's not
enough either okay they're goop yeah
they're goop do you think they're not
interested in what's happening here
because you're a bunch of elitist
Hollywood scumbags
I think that they have an allegiance to
all of us because literally everyone
standing behind you looks like they have
[__] terabytes of child porn
we bring joy to their lives we bring
enter listen to this
this is what Hollywood people think that
we bring joy to their life no people's
families bring joy to their lives and
Annie wasn't that good of a show and it
was a long time ago it wasn't brought
anybody joined a long time and by the
way and then Alex Borstein come steals
your voice and does a better job than
you that's gotta hurt right that hurts
right
entertainment to their lives and during
covid they turn to us for everything no
oh my God
the [__] the amount of
self-importance here
the comments have to be I mean I can't
imagine the comments are positive
this is so out of touch
they came to us in their time and need
for everything we gave them everything
we gave them a raise I think that your
assumption that they don't really care
about anything but being entertained
over the summer yes danced almost here
about do you think that you were saving
lives you sang an imagined song and
pushed an experimental experimental
vaccine you have more [__] blood on
your hands than Lindsey Graham not on
your team until DMX [__] oh
you guys ever see that [__] the
Imagine song that all the celebrities
saying did you did you guys ever see the
[__] guy who did like he played the
chords underneath of it yeah like kept
it in key so he kept have them play it's
[__] [__] dude yeah they're not
great yeah for the summer is the bottom
line when the people that give so much
to them and enrich their lives in so
many ways are saying we are being taken
advantage the people that enrich their
no no we enrich your lives literally we
give you money you would give you money
so you could live this [__] lifestyle
holy believable [__] they think they're
Gods
actors used to be treated like
prostitutes as they should we should do
that again but let's go back to the
Marilyn Monroe treatment of of them okay
job in a terrible way and if we let this
happen to US dollars for donuts it's
gonna happen to you and your family your
children
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no it's not
gonna happen to people other do you
think that teachers unions and
pipefitters unions are going like hey
look if they could get away with it in
Hollywood let's do it of these slums
you're [__] that's not how this
works okay
do you think the police Union is waiting
to see what Hollywood's doing and the
strike goes on forever
did you hear about Deadpool
yeah he's not a lot of ad-lib
Ryan
Reynolds
Deadpool playing Deadpool Ryan Reynolds
is not allowed to ad-lib in the movie
that the account is writing it counts as
writing as the ad-lib so again I want to
point this out that pool movie is going
to suck there Ryan Reynolds
whose whole thing is [__] improving
right he was the funniest part of play
Trinity
you're telling him he's got it this is
like ah due to the writers strike uh Big
Jake Big Jay oakerson's not allowed to
do crowd work and he can be like wait a
minute what and he has to wear normal
gloves
no fingerless ones apparently did you
know it was the same Union I had no idea
could you imagine that you're like you
book a show and then Jay Orbison comes
he's your headliner and you're like just
two seconds before you get to that stage
you're like and Now ladies and gentlemen
with big Jay oakerson and you go oh by
the way don't interact with the crowd
what no crowd work good luck out there
what yeah
that's hard to believe but here we are
Hollywood is on hold this morning actors
have joined writers in the first joint
strike and stuff yeah the strike is
impacting even our Movie Crew
backstageol.com Dave Morales even
explain and break it all down babe I
remember those seven strike I remember
how impactful that you will start with
the new deal here well explain the 307
strike remember that all the people at
Hollywood resorts to cannibalism yeah me
too
reason it's huge right now is because
you have the Riders the wga also on
strike this is the first time it's
happened since 1960 along with the
Screen Actors Guild I'm a member of
after it does it impact me I work in
Texas or a right to work state so it's
really not going to be a question
at what age
is a nose ring a little much for a man
specifically also [__] three years
old if you're gonna wear a backwards hat
don't like it's loose weird when the
back isn't like tight
well no because it's solid like there's
no strap or anything like that's a ball
cap but it looks like he's wearing one
of those like Muslim
cats yeah but it's also it's also too
big
yeah he looks like like they're like a
reboot of the movie Big
you know like like he just made a wish
and a machine and then he suddenly but
he's still wearing his middle schoolers
he's wearing a Rocawear shirt
look look at the pocket where do you
even find that now Ross
next to the broken Bluetooth speakers a
[__] loser
oh man this loser
hold on we gotta look at this guy I'm
fascinated by this [__] Dave Morales
this guy sucks Dave Morales at Backstage
we've played him on the show before I
think this guy sucks
backstage ol
Dave back okay Dave backstage ol
Morales [__] stinks burning me Ryder
uh writers and actors I need to make
their money so you shouldn't torrent
movie shows don't put them on USB drives
and share them you definitely shouldn't
cancel Netflix and give that money to
our ROTC yeah it's a good point also on
strike why is Dave dude I can't get over
the fact that Dave Morales stressed like
everyone I knew in Middle School no no
for real he's probably wearing Mark Echo
jeans too
[Laughter]
take the bus to the next I don't know
man his Osiris's are pretty sweet look
look he puts his lugs on one foot at a
time just like the rest of us okay yeah
nice airwalks
he's like the kid who's the skater but
also listen to Wu-Tang
this is the first time it's happened
since 1960 along with the Screen Actors
Guild I'm a member of after it doesn't
impact me I work in Texas or a right to
work state so it's really not going to
impact me uh as a member of no one was
asking after I did not vote on the
strike but um meaning that I was not
even given a ballot because I'm not sad
I'm just after but you know uh the
Director's Guild they have a deal they
work to deal out so I'm confident about
that what this boils down to is really
AI artificial intelligence reactors
don't want to be replaced and streaming
residuals Netflix Disney they're making
a lot of money right now they don't have
to report ratings there it's all
subscriber based so you get these uh
series like the big Disney ones or the
Star Wars ones and the actors a lot of
the actors are still earning scale yeah
but you but you agree to that when don't
do the show no no hold on a second
then don't do the show
no one's making you be in the
Mandalorian okay
no one's making you be in the new Star
Wars [__] pumped out Disney [__]
all right no one's making you be in
[__] frankly I'm getting really sick
of all Disney bad quartering videos but
no one's making you be in those okay
a black mermaid I'm so angry
me too
there's the the logic here bottom half
of the black Little Mermaid was a
catfish is that how many people know
that getting a lot of maps tilapia
money for these shows ew I hate tilapia
so much I know you want a real fish no
let's pay the Riders and the actors more
can you explain more about Ai and who
that would work was Allen Iverson he
everybody knows who Allen Iverson is
we're very famous basketball player he
had shoes and everything place and what
they're so concerned about what type of
jobs actors the acting jobs so basically
they're worried that you can get an
actor's image and then use it over and
over and over again it's already
happening with some audience shots that
they've taken where they recycle the
audience members
into other shows so
I don't care I don't care about anything
I hope they do people I hope all these
people that [__] sold their soul to
the machine are replaced by AI versions
of themselves I hope that happens
yeah I mean I look we've already pointed
out we never cared about this writer
strike in the first place because you've
just been cranking out [__] paint by
numbers [__] anyway and you can't
replace us because chat CPT won't say
the n-word so good luck yeah we are
essential workers
Mitchell workers now
Ace
as long as you're racist you're
irreplaceable as long as you're erases
you're irreplaceable AI cannot replace
you
they will not replace us they will not
replace us you just blew my [__] mind
[__] this is a digital
Charlottesville
Charlottesville all I have to do is put
the n-word on glass pipes and AI machine
learning what are they gonna do what are
you gonna do you woke yourself into a
corner now we're Irreplaceable
things like that they've already been
doing this and the actors are saying
don't do it with us if you do uh then
you're gonna have to pay us a lot more
and that makes sense yeah cool it really
does how long could this go oh [__] bro
they got my username
that was my username user123 that's one
two three that's me yeah
could this go passwords one two three
four five yeah that's a combination of
my luggage
okay great question because there are
two things that are being impacted right
now immediately the uh Comic-Con which
is going on in San Diego nobody cares
the studies have pulled out people have
bought tickets to that thing they're
expecting panels Disney's out Warners
out there's a lot of Studios that will
not be at Comic-Con it won't be like now
it's Blum House It's Time To Shine the
big boys aren't going to be at the cons
wait for that they them sequel It's a
common ahead of the curb fellas think
you may all right Comic Con of the past
the other one is the Toronto Film
Festival which we always go to that's
why I was renewing my passport yesterday
that's the first step towards the awards
campaign Mr Dax goes Virgie has another
set of numbers in his username jackkat
35 ma'am I'm a commercial plumber I
guess I could ask chat CPT how to run
sewer groundwork trains water lines and
regular drains for a four-story
apartment complex but my phone can't
actually do that
pipefitters are gonna be fine
and it's a huge Festival in Toronto John
and I John yeah the difference is when
pipefitters go on strike you go Jesus we
gotta [__] negotiate with these guys
we can't not have those guys yeah here's
something it's like with the truckers or
garbage man garbage men we're striking
we're like fix this when garbage men
strike okay we're everywhere you rent a
limo yeah we know
everyone's like when garbageman strike
everyone's like look we need to fix this
and we need to [__] fix this now
because it's starting to smell and we're
getting rats everyone's like duh when
you know what you know how behind I am
on shows and you're making so much
garbage now you already made good shows
I'll just re-watch those you should have
went on strike the last season of Better
Call Saul yeah
but it's already out now I was the last
good show that came out yeah we're fine
I gotta point this out real quick I'll
watch The Sopranos again yeah lonely
chef and chat said what song is that
jacket
and that's very funny and by the way I
think you should leave's not going to be
affected do you think that guy writes
anything
I uh is not done by him it's done
through him yeah
that show feels like it's written by AI
though doesn't it like it's so like the
turns for no reason
yeah see because the metal Lord Maniac
uses the wall is the ground for the
middle Lord Maniac that's what it is
we do our first slip is there something
wrong with romaniac my kid's not talking
to me
uh move interviews for the upcoming
award season uh Tiff as we call it if it
doesn't happen that's in September so
the answer is perfect yeah it's a huge
impact and think about the nice legs on
this broad though
nice legs on her people that work in
crowd services the caters we have
friends that produce these interviews uh
they're out of work right or they're on
hold right now until all this gets
resolved how long will it go nobody has
the answer I don't think it's going to
be very long because the studios are
just rebounding from the pandemic
theaters as well they don't want to
start losing money again because they
lost a ton during the pandemic so hey
Dave buy a new wardrobe he's an idiot
bro I mean it's a [__] idiot it's
really bad right right it looks like a
Tim Robinson character he does he looks
like he would be Cameron's producer
that's really funny he's dressed like
[__] turtle from Entourage that's
what it is
you [__] nailed it turtle from
Entourage that's exactly what he's
dressed like 100 I looked up his
Instagram his Instagram looks like
turtles Instagram friends yes
you got it right there